welcome oh
no no welcome to you keep all this you
you've sabotaged me last time Paul you
keep all this in the intro
welcome to the across the spoiler verse
podcast I'm your host
bag as a butthole
got him in the end you sucker yeah lots
of stuff to talk about this week as
always I'm joined by Greg from real
rejects he's getting into his yoga pose
as per usual he loves sitting with his
legs crossed dropping the knowledge
how's it going Greg it's going great
Paul I did not sleep much because
yesterday was the day where everyone on
social media was trying to figure out
what influencers can do and cannot do
when it comes to this sack strike and so
I it was just like non-stop all day I
message you a ton but it's gonna be one
of our main topics today is uh the sack
strike and probably go over a little bit
of what influencers can't have with
everything I was able to gather uh it's
like a lot of cross-referencing but we
also got some awesome box office stuff
to talk about yeah you were telling me
beforehand about some little mermaid
stuff
um and of course Mission Impossible is
if a dead reckoning part one it's the
big one and yeah then something about
the flash that you quickly casually
dropped in there so
you're the boss man what is the uh what
is the first topic you want to talk
about my friend
so yeah lots of stuff to talk about
um Mission Impossible box office just
box offices in general uh Indiana Jones
has now crossed 300 million at the box
office so yeah not that good to be
honest
um it's kind of really struggling to to
get to the point where it's gonna even
match its its budget and uh it's dropped
out of a lot of showings unfortunately
and
some Pace to be one of the uh the
biggest flops in Disney history
apparently so that's a pretty crazy way
to start the week especially with the
the studios at the moment and everything
that's going on now The Little Mermaid
that has uh it's apparently sitting
right under
550 million now according to deadline
the break-even point is 560 million so
it's got 10 million to make to break
even obviously you know this is a Kids
film
um I know a lot of adults went to see it
but you know they're gonna have toys and
and merch in it so yeah probably will
hit a point where the IP is profitable
and it will make its money back
obviously you know that was one of the
first topics we talked about
The Flash though it's actually it it's
it's hitting the point where it's gonna
end its theatrical run I mean it
releases digitally tomorrow as of this
recording
and it's gonna and it's theatrical run
making less than Green Lantern did at
the box office
[Music]
terrible oh man yeah and if you think
about how much they hype this movie up
they say it was one of the best comic
book movies of all time it was gonna be
bigger than the Dark Knight anything
you'd ever seen
no not that good and uh obviously when
it hits digital tomorrow that's just
gonna completely kill kill it uh so yeah
but also Insidious yeah doing really
well it's already past 120 million
worldwide and it's on a 16 million
dollar budget so really really outpacing
its uh its budget there done really well
for itself not not heard much you know
saying the movie's good but uh it might
even close out as being bigger than the
flash as well
um sound of Freedom as well I think
that's scheduled to to probably I wish I
had the data in front of me right now
I'm doing this for memory but I'm sure I
read that it was going to pass 100
million at the box office as well so
yeah lots of uh lots of winners lots of
losers lots of things going on and uh
yeah that kind of takes us into Mission
Impossible dead reckoning weekend box
office
can I interject before we get to the
awesome box office of my man Tom Cruise
um I want to say it's real I appreciate
that thank you for your permission so
when it comes to Little Mermaid
um I've noticed because a lot of these
movies have this like 45 day theatrical
window before they hit video on demand
or streaming and it it's that it's past
the 45 day window Mark am I not am I
correct about that and it's still not on
video on demand they kind of killed that
recently I think I think they might have
killed it with Ant-Man because I'm sure
Ant-Man released much later I remember
because I'm a big 4K collector yeah I
remember that it dropped on Disney plus
after the physical media release and for
some reason Disney in there they're
genius they decided to release it on
Disney plus no before like the movies
that they started putting on Disney plus
when it's like we're doing IMAX
presentations on Disney plus of all our
Marvel movies
they were releasing it in 4k IMAX Disney
plus first and then the 4K Blu-ray not
an IMAX like a month after and it just
made no sense and then uh obviously that
was killing a revenue stream there but
the Geniuses are over at Disney as we
can tell by all the amazing
um budgets and spending but they uh yeah
the Ant-Man I remember being the one
where the Blu-ray dropped first and I
think they realized like oh crap we are
kind of killing a lot of our sales here
by releasing them in high quality 4K
IMAX aspect ratio for free on air Disney
Plus Port before it all drops but yeah
there's been an average every Studio has
been uh still doing pretty much that for
like uh just watched Transformers last
week
um so uh whatever it's called rise of
the Beast and that was a 45 day window
but yeah I'm looking here Guardians 3
came out three months after it premiered
in the theaters so
that did all that did well financially
too
um a 140 million worldwide and the
little mermaid is picking up so it seems
like Disney at least was the first one
to their credit in a day and age where
they are not getting good publicity for
many just reasons
one of the smart things they've done is
go we shouldn't abide by this 45 day
window for video on demand because it'll
allow us to still reap some profit in
the in the theatrical window and uh or
other studios are
um still pretty much releasing their
stuff at 45 day window marks yeah it
just makes absolutely no sense why they
did this in the first place they kind of
set the boundaries for themselves and I
think a lot of problem with like the the
box office at the moment is very low and
to me this is because the the movie
studios have trained people to realize
that movies are going to release in a
short window to watch at home like very
very quickly after they've been in the
cinema and it just makes no sense to me
why they even put that in place if if
you're asking me like Paul how are we
gonna release this stuff to make the
most money I'd go theater first
digitally for sale pay on demand
then Blu-ray with extra features that
you can't get on the digital and then
like way down the line for free on
streaming because if you release it in
the cinema and then free on streaming
like
and then Blu-ray after it like only
idiot to collect physical media still
are gonna pay for that stuff so yeah it
just seemed completely stupid looking
back and uh they deserve to burn in hell
for all that they've done to the film
industry
yeah I seen like David zaslab this like
is on half a billion dollars wages in
the last four years or something I'm
just thinking Jesus the guys came in and
completely destroyed the company but you
know I mean if Warner Brothers want to
pay me half a billion dollars to come in
and completely gut the company for the
next four years I'll do it guys I I'm
down to do that job you don't worry
about it I'll come in and do it so yeah
the mission impossible opening weekend
um it's brought in domestic sales from
Friday to Sunday was 56.2 million and 80
million since it's Wednesday opening
um apparently this is set a franchise
record but it's underperforming
expectations
so it's uh it's it's been a weird one
like reading this because the reactions
are kind of all over the place with it
some are saying it's great
um globally it's done really well so
it's earned 235 million
um and it's opening weekend but there
there's kind of like a weird thing
around this where it's like well you you
guys said that
Indiana Jones did terrible and it it's
the mission impossible didn't make that
much money like in comparison but yeah I
feel like Mission Impossible is gonna
have legs this has stronger reviews
strong reviews and stronger audience
score and that is usually a Telltale
sign that it'll have legs and that's
something to really really factor in and
it's only it came in 10 million dollars
domestically under expectation it wasn't
like a disaster you know what I mean
like they were expecting 90 million
ideally you want to over perform past
that but it's 80 million compared to 90
million is not as it's not as bad as
we've been hearing lately you know and
so yeah it'll have legs yeah I mean
you've obviously got Barbie and
Oppenheimer coming this weekend which
will probably you know take away a lot
of the profit that it could have got
because it's going to be eating up those
screens but I mean top gun Maverick that
didn't really have a strong start and it
was just a case of people constantly
going back and re-watching it now this
is obviously now your three hour film I
don't know if it's gonna have the repeat
viewings but
I think it's good I think you know it's
doing well Tom Cruise top gun Maverick
was his first ever billion dollar film
um so I mean he's not like no he's
obviously a big movie star but you know
what I mean he wasn't like not like
getting billions every single film
um but it seems now that he's entered
the club you know people are kind of on
board and I think this is gonna have
legs and people are gonna go back and
see it now whether that turns out to be
true or not we'll see what Bobby and
Oppenheimer do but pretty good
you know solid start not a disaster like
some places are making it out to be and
yeah I don't think it's gonna do all
right remember I mean this doesn't seem
to be the case because it seems like Tom
Cruise and you know null Tom Cruise
especially seems to be very supportive I
don't know if it's just publicity PR
Optics if it's if it is rooted in
sincerity I feel like it would be
because in or in order for everything to
change in the movie theater in the
cinemas we it does need to be encouraged
that everyone just keeps consistently
going you can't just have one movie be a
hit you know and so there was that story
like that was spreading it was just a
rumor that Tom Cruise is like really
upset about how uh it's gonna leave IMAX
uh at a week because it's only going to
be there for like a week as
oppenheimer's is eating it up for many
many many weeks following which is kind
of unheard of nowadays usually they the
movies only have a small window like two
to two weeks or something at most a lot
of the time now uh to be the one that is
occupying the iMac screen things
but you know like you see Tom Cruise
supporting Oppenheimer and Barbie and go
to go you know go watch these movies but
I'm reading here uh I believe this is
yeah this is from deadline
that plfs and iMacs actually drove 42 of
the weekend's gross as so IMAX uh
reported a 25 million dollar Global
opening and then that made me go yeah
that's exactly why uh that story was
coming out and we know how much Tom
Cruise is a champion for uh watching his
movies in the iMac screens I did watch
this uh re I did uh my second viewing of
it yesterday I thought my opinion would
really change it didn't change that much
I was like no this looks a lot better on
I I think it's it's more way more
enjoyable on IMAX for sure
um but my opinion of the movie overall
actually didn't really change that much
but the but the experience of IMAX I'm
like yeah this is this is why it's worth
it however a massive difference though
is between you know Mission Impossible
and Oppenheimer and you could tell just
from when they played the Oppenheimer
trailer beforehand
to justify why Oppenheimer deserves a
little bit more time in the theaters
than Mission Impossible is they shot
that with like real IMAX cameras
Oppenheimer where if you go to a real
iMac screen movies like Mission
Impossible only take up the center of
the screen so you got these like Giant
letterboxes and the movies in the center
granted Chris quality they shot up with
a certain kind of IMAX camera but it's
not the full-fledged one that Nolan
shoots with so when you watch
Oppenheimer it's going to be like taking
up the entire screen and the projection
quality like the HD digital quad
whatever not digital film but the HD
quality of it like the details like that
that's a more Justified IMAX experience
more than Mission Impossible just due to
that
so I just thought that was a like fun
little tidbit considering that story was
you know going around about him being
upset
yeah which is fair enough I'd be upset
about people taking my movie away from
me so
we've got movies are getting taken away
from us which is a nice segue and that
is because there's lots of strikes going
on in Hollywood right now now I've been
asked a number of times to do a fully
fledged video on this explaining
everything I've cut I'm a bit
I don't know all of the ins and outs of
it and I I think you know I've mentioned
this on the the podcast before if I by
getting Easter egg wrong it's not the
end of the world but if I say something
in a video like that and it gets you
know my audience or even a fraction of
it to turn against those people who are
trying to get themselves either better
pay or whatever
you know that's that's bad on my behalf
um so I just want to treat it with as
much respect as possible
um but it's very strange because last
week yeah we had a thumbnail for the
video that we're gonna we're actually
gonna reuse this thumbnail so last week
the the thumbnail that you you're seeing
now that was originally going to be used
on on that video but we were talking we
were like you know what this podcast
it's really negative all the time well
we seem to talk about is box office
bombs and how much Hollywood's kind of
ruining everything so I thought no we'll
go with a nicer thumbnail that seems
more positive but then when we got to
this one we were like you know what we
can probably use the thumbnail from last
week and just not change anything it
doesn't go to waste it doesn't go to
waste we're so lucky yeah it was it was
talking about how um Hollywood's
basically been destroyed by greed and
we've seen that everyone like writers
sag actors are all striking at the
moment and just refusing to work until
they get Fair pay better residuals and
Healthcare and also don't get AI is
involved as it is and we're going to be
trying to cover as much as we can in
this video to explain as simply as
possible what's going on with that you
know we might get some things wrong if
you if we do then you know the comment
section is the perfect place to correct
us or just talk about your feelings in
general towards it but the strikes
themselves
um so they started last week we did kind
of get the suspicion that something was
off because I'm sure if you guys are
watching YouTube they dropped so many
trailers on one day
um and it everyone was just kind of
panicking behind the scenes I hit a
point where I was like you know what I'm
not gonna do breakdowns of these because
it's like 5 p.m and I've been working
all day and bit tired but something
seemed off for that many trailers to
drop now in hindsight why they did this
was because they knew that the strike
was starting the next day and stars
couldn't be seen actively promoting
their works and so on
um and then we we obviously got to the
point where that the strikes hit
bye-bye just comes out and bloody what
an idiot what a complete idiot just what
he said he was saying that you know it's
a disturbing time for the Hollywood to
go on strike it's like mate they're not
going to go on strike when it's
convenient for you guys you know what I
mean it's not going to be like oh can we
I like I've seen this post the other
week about teachers going on strike in
Britain and and one of the the
politicians saying it was like can they
not wait until the summer holidays
before they go on strike and say oh yeah
well wait actually till five o'clock and
go on strike and put the kids to bed
like strikes are supposed to be
disruptive
um and obviously that's what they've
done now lots of Productions are shut
down there's barely any one kind of um
talking about like you can't work at the
moment um if you're in America even in
the UK where they're filming things like
House of the Dragon we're not
technically affected by it and there's
actually a rule in our strikes that you
can't
strike in solidarity with another Union
if that makes sense so the people in the
UK who are part of a union they can just
go well I'm not bothering anymore so how
so the dragons actually being filmed but
Matt Smith gangster Damon Damon and the
sack he just was like no I'm not working
either so he's left that
um oh did he I didn't I didn't hear
about that he did yeah I'm pretty sure I
read that he might not have but yeah I'm
pretty sure I read that he just like was
like no I'm not doing it mate studies
and obviously he's a big star so the car
really he's he's the main draw yeah oh
that's cool I didn't know that that's
awesome
so yeah I mean I after you hear Bob
iger's comments you are kind of like I
mean this is how tone deaf it was so
they were asking for money and Bob Iger
was away on something they call like a
Billionaire Boys Club break or something
summer like billionaire summer camp is
the main thing yeah exactly billionaire
summer camp and he's like oh it's really
really bad they keep asking for more
money and it's like
I think the thing people are kind of
getting misconstrued here is when you
say Hollywood actor a lot of people
immediately assume people like the rock
Tom Cruise
you know these well-paid actors who are
at the top now there's actually 160 000
people who are affected by these strikes
can you name 160
000 actors Greg nope you can't nope
exactly so that gives you an idea of
who's actually like getting affected by
its mainly background actors and the
main actors like the big names they're
striking in solidarity with them to just
be like look we know we get paid a
shitload we're just doing it support and
you could tell things were like it it
got a lot of attention straight away
because during the premiere of
Oppenheimer the entire cast just got up
I was like right we're off yeah movies
three hours long we're off okay so no
they didn't do it because of that they
they were striking in solidarity with
them and heading out and yeah it was it
was good of them
you also seen clips from Sean Gunn
um on the picket line I know that Mark
ruffalo's been there Sean sort of got in
a bit of trouble
um but he did completely crap on Bob
Iger and he was saying how he started
asking like in in 1980 there was the
footy type like the the lowest paid
worker the CEO got 40 times that in
2023 they get 200 times that you should
ask yourself why well that's disturbing
Bob and I just saw bloody hell mate
Craig then he's getting killed on the
way back to his home planet you know
what I mean
um Ron Perlman he caused a bit of a stir
because he's one of the studio heads
yeah one of the studio heads basically
came out and said the end gate and this
is in regards to the writer's strike but
it's a strategy that I'm guessing
they're gonna gonna get for the the
actors too yeah the end game is to allow
things to drag on until union members
start losing their apartments and losing
their houses
comes out and goes there's plenty of
other ways to lose your house S8 bloody
up they got he doesn't just play a tough
guy on TV he's a tough guy on Twitter as
well uh so yeah he's he kind of implied
violence he did walk it back the next
day but these statements got a hell of a
lot of publicity now if we go back to
the history of the strikes
this is the first time in 60 years that
both are writers and actors have struck
at the same time and what tends to
happen historically is that
it's always with the emergence of a new
technology so in the 60s television had
just been you know television was really
starting to pick up to show movies on it
um it was a new way to to broadcast
things and hackers weren't getting paid
for it now in the 80s that was another
point where a strike happened and that
was during the emergence of VHS so films
were getting sold physically and you
could buy them and watch them at home
we obviously hitting a point now at
streaming services
um and the residuals on it are
absolutely terrible it was like an
actress from Orange is the New Black who
posted her residual check and she got
like 29 or something crazy
um and yeah it's just kind of hit a
point where the studios are clearly
clearly making a lot of money on this
stuff but they're also not paying people
fairly
um there's been numerous actors who came
out and talked about how they've had to
get they've been on massive television
shows but they've had to get second jobs
because it it doesn't cover their living
expenses and obviously you know I think
everyone can agree watching this
everyone deserves to be paid if they
have a full-time job they should be paid
to a point where they're not panicking
about like staying alive you should be
comfortable and when the industry
evolves and change that's the whole
point of the strikes that you were
talking about emergence of new
technologies and stuff when the industry
is evolving
the pays the payments should evolve to
and and be adjusted to match or help
compensate for that especially with the
with the level of demand uh that they
put on writers and actors especially you
know like the best thing about the SAG
strike I think for for everything I mean
other than like obviously getting
fighting for what they deserve
is that
I mean the writers have been treated so
the writers are between so apparently
for so long that this this helps in
conjunction with them as well to be able
to fight the good fight together as well
so that's the one thing I'm really
looking forward to about what the and
end outcome of this even though it seems
like it's going to last [__] forever
because about like the studios are
because those are the lights there's not
much the problem is is that this whole
thing needs to be negotiated and and
from at least the rhetoric from what the
writers say from sag saying is that
negotiation seems so minimal and sparse
as much as they try to negotiate and
talk it out it's like it doesn't it's
not like it's a big ping-pong game of
going back and forth it's like we're
just kind of we're trying to negotiate
but we're not being negotiated with is
kind of what the what the conversation
seems to sound like from what we're
hearing from sagging the wga
so it's a lot of unfairness
like what a studio is what a billion
dollar Corporation that's already got
billions in the bank is gonna do is not
gonna negotiate they are gonna be
[__] about it because they can
there's no re like they're not
struggling yet and they can totally just
drag this out for as long as they want
because they're pieces of [__] they
don't really care about the workers they
care about the bottom line so even my
dog's getting mad about it and a company
they're not gonna show they're weak
because if they do then everyone's gonna
strike all the time so what they do in
general as a general practice is just
drag things out as long as possible and
they normally wait until it may you know
it looks like they're not gonna give
anything and then they give a bit and
it's like well it's not what we fully
wanted but we'll accept and then we can
get back to work and everything it's a
it's an improvement
um and that's just it well corporations
tend to do in general regarding strikes
they're not going to be like day one
showing up like oh yeah I will give you
what you want just come back to work
they're going to drag it out as long as
possible because they can and they know
that that's the way to treat things
basically
um and there's obviously like the
streaming services they're really really
killing things at the moment because
that they're refusing to give their
their viewing numbers so no one can even
tell how well the show's doing now what
they've said is like the the actors and
writers have came in and said well we'll
we'll come in with a we'll we'll accept
a third party that can view the the
numbers and analytics and then they'll
come up with the viewing figures but the
studio said uh no no yeah we're not
going to do that actually because those
viewing figures might not be accurate
and it's like okay well can you do it
is that all either so it's kind of like
you're pulling hair trying to get you
know how well your show's done
um and they're just really being as
frustrating as possible and they've
introduced this absolutely insane Black
Mirror Jonas awful level AI technology
where they scan background actors pay
them a one-off fee and they own their
likeness
till the end of time
what are your thoughts on that Greg do
you think that's a fair deal oh God I
mean man's gotta do what a man's gotta
do business is business Paul no of
course it's not fair to you man this is
a absolutely horrendous things I think
restrictive guidelines in this situation
are massively important this is like
some of the scariest AI [__] ever
because a lot of the Time background
there are some people I I mean like I
said I'm in La so I've gotten to know
like all different kinds of camps here
when it comes to the acting field you
know and you know I myself obviously not
a non-union stack member but I know
plenty of people who are and especially
like with the background feel there are
people who make their living doing
background work some people like that
profession other people there's others
who will start off doing background work
before they start doing some type of
principal role or a one-liner in
something as they're as they're in the
audition process they just they're
getting on set and making their money
doing background work so to be able to
do this
I mean no actor should ever agree to
anything like this I don't think on
whatever level of acting you are I
believe there was something even from
I'm just remembering right now that
Samuel Jackson he was offered this and
he absolutely refused to do it because
he saw the consequences ahead of time of
what they could do and it's kind of
funny coming from a show where they're
opening credits are generated by an AI
for the most part uh but yeah no this is
a this is a terrible idea because
I mean let's say you are one of those
people who's a background hey you mean
you won't be able to work again doing
the background work and B if you are one
of those people who wants to graduate to
actual acting one day instead of just
doing background work like you were just
doing this as a little gig
they own your likeness so that will
prevent you from being able to pursue
that opportunity or at least limit you
you know we don't know what the true ins
and outs of of what the limitations are
of what your career would you know
ultimately be able to go down the path
of but I can't imagine it's a good one I
can't imagine that this is all something
that is a positive uh yeah you gotta
really regulate the use of AI here it's
super duper important and it's this is
terrifying stuff plus it just doesn't
look good for the most part I understand
they like do it it just looks so [__]
fake so I hope they don't do it yeah
Chris stuckman he actually explained a
lot of stuff using Ben Affleck and Matt
Damon as a great example so those two
guys they start off as background actors
yeah
well just background actors on lots of
different things went to lots of
different Studios you know got to
observe filmmaking got to see how actors
work learn a lot of things work their
way up drop the script for Goodwill
Hunting got themselves a job
big big movie stars now graduated to
that now if if they'd scan their
likeness none of that stuff would have
happened that's exactly my yeah that's
exactly my point yeah
it would have went in day one got
scanned
there's your check 200 or whatever see
you later they go back to to get a job
again oh sorry uh you could you caught
we've actually already got your likeness
we don't need you and they'll just get
someone else and scan them and they'll
just build up a library of likenesses
Now Matt Damon and Ben Affleck look
they're like oh that sucks okay well
we'll go work at this studio instead
they go over there that's Judy goes
actually we can't like use you guys
because Warner Brothers who or whoever
you just worked for they own your
likeness so you for that one day's work
you've destroyed your career yep um
you're getting the one day's pay
you're out of it it's completely insane
like Black Mirror have their finger on
the pulse right now because if you watch
Jonas awful it goes over this and using
people's likenesses and owning it
basically and yet
just so scary thinking what they could
do so a couple weeks back yeah after the
flash dropped uh I did a video talking
about bringing back dead actors and you
know I I was like I think it's
distasteful the general consensus was
that look if you get permission from the
estate or the family then it's okay to
bring them back now what I'm guessing
this AI stuff's gonna do is that let's
say there's a Superman actor who comes
in they'll scan him
yeah they'll get his likeness
40 years later or something he dies
the studio at this Point's like let's
get him in a cameo in a film
in a really weird scene they don't they
own the likeness to that guy now so they
don't have to even ask for this like the
permission to do it because they own the
likeness right and also like we we've
just seen Indiana Jones we've seen what
you know what the point they're getting
to now in terms of
using basically full-on deep fakes on
people it's the same with Luke Skywalker
and the Mandalorian
the technology it's not fully there yet
but it will get there very soon I'm
talking next 10 15 years Max I'll figure
out how to do it so it's completely
seamless and you don't notice it at all
now say you scan and act as likeness
like a big A-list star
let's go back to the Superman example
say David Curran sweats coming in is
Superman he makes a really good
performance everyone loves him the thing
he's the best Superman ever and
unfortunately you know 30 years from now
he dies or something now they bring a
stunt man in
who has a similar sort of body to him
replace his head with day recurrent
sweat I don't know why I pronounce it
like that David Corinth sweat uh and at
this point as well they've also got the
the the technology down to where
someone's voice can be faked as well
because they're sort of dabbling in that
at the moment as well so they've
basically brought David Curran sweat
back to life through the use of AI now
at this point they can just keep
Wheeling him out until the end of time
to play Superman they never need to
recast him ever so it's all
always going to be Superman now imagine
let's say in the 70s they had an inkling
that this technology was coming and they
got Christopher Reeve to scan away his
entire likeness
Chris do you think they're going to be
recasting Superman at this point when
everyone's constantly like Christopher
Reeves the ultimate Superman he's the
perfect actor who's ever played him no
what they would do is just deep fake him
until the end of time we'd never get a
new Superman actors coming in because
they just constantly CGI that guy in to
the point where he's always gonna play
Superman and forever and ever and ever
yeah and yeah it's just getting to this
really weird point where
that it's gonna destroy jobs like
literally professions overnight and what
I don't get is why the Hollywood studio
can't like the the execs and stuff can't
see how how replaceable they are to for
example yeah Bob Iger I mean Disney
let's be honest yeah they're not exactly
the kings of original IPS I'm pretty
sure that an AI could come in and be
like
make Toy Story five you know what I mean
I don't feel like Bubba is fully
Justified and getting all these actors
replaced so I'm pretty sure an AI could
come in and lose less money than that
guy's been losing at Disney
so they need they really need to put the
brakes on it get things in place
protection for people and their
livelihoods because I tell you every
single job will be at risk including
mine I'm sure it could easily debake my
voice and talk rubbish every week for an
hour
it's gonna get to that point I feel like
this like the jobs of granted I mean you
know for full clarification obviously we
don't know everything that like Bob Iger
or you know zazlov does right but we
know that they're not the creative heads
on these things they make everything
they do is like business analytical
numbers you know and if there's anything
that could be AI replaced it's their
jobs like the CEOs because they can just
get all the numbers they need of if
they're trying to make a business
decision on which property to focus on
how much money should go into something
which one would be best and you have
your algorithm machine that could take
all the data
and then it can make the decision on
like this should be the thing to focus
on with the budgets and all these like
whatever the decision making is it could
all come down to an AI more so than the
creatives because
like the correct that's the thing about
this these like CEOs within the studio
heads it's like so Bo bothers sums like
they're they're not even like on set and
most of the time you know like vast vast
vast majority of the time they don't
even do like a set visit
where you don't see how how much labor
goes into all these things to make it
all happen you know and when it comes to
the writers when it comes to the actors
and
the fact that they just they're treating
them like what they're asking for is
unfair it's so it's [__] it is
complete [__] when they're like yes
they they would gladly replace an actor
or writer with a computer
definitely like there's no question
about it if they can do it they
absolutely will and what they like what
you were bringing up what they fail to
realize is like I think their jobs are
easier to replace and then than a writer
or an actor actually
especially for the money they take from
the company yeah Bob Iger gets 25
million dollars a year and then bonuses
on top we're looking at a lot of money
coming out the company to pay for this
guy who they could probably hand half of
his job over to AI I mean I'm pretty
sure you know they can't the computer
can come in and be like let's make this
old cartoon a live action movie you know
what I mean I think there's I think the
AI can figure that out
and yeah it's just like do you not
realize how disposable everyone is when
you start making these practices and
like common it's uh it's very
short-sighted I think Hollywood's kind
of running itself into the ground and
when we look at the issues over the last
couple of years like
Bob I get he obviously had the big push
towards Disney plus and he he was
talking about how Marvel and Star Wars
they've kind of realized that
pushing them as TV shows on a streaming
service has killed their brand and their
appeal because it's you know made the if
if the TV shows had all been completely
incredible HBO level type dramas and
stuff I think you know it would have
been a different story but it's clear
that they've went for Quality uh
quantity of a quality and just seeing
him like say this completely blew my
mind because one of the most like basic
lessons in business is about brand
fatigue and it is it says don't over
like don't oversaturate your product
because it will kill The Branding people
will get sick of seeing it everywhere
they'll no longer be interested
and it's seeing a billion dollar
Corporation learn this in real time
completely blew my mind and I tell you
what the AI they would have figured that
out months and months ago
um yeah and I mean we could have said it
like last year like these Disney Plus
shows they seem to be kind of killing
off exactly like the things that you've
built up into these massive IPS and yeah
just seeing the CEO come out with that
he's saying that they're gonna scale
back the amount of money that they put
into these Studios yeah and it's like
well you could keep the money the same
just don't do as many and don't do as
many mid to met ones well this is the
part was what he's talking about with
like the the disappointing stuff that's
happened because it wasn't just Disney
you know like everyone was we gotta it's
not just we gotta be Netflix they wanted
to beat Netflix as well they just really
wanted to dominate the streaming Wars as
much as possible which put an insane
Demand on the writers as well so
they're talk like when Bob iger's
statements
um uh talking about what did he say like
it's how it's like disruptive what's
happening in the in the industry
and what these writers are fighting for
I'm like well this all began like the
thing that you're talking about with how
the industry is struggling especially
with uh movie theater releases and stuff
a lot of that was because of terrible
decision making that happened when it
came to we gotta beat Netflix we gotta
be better than Netflix where you've
essentially programmed your audience to
you know sometimes I still even for me
as someone who who does love going to
the theaters I will get that thought of
like well I'll just wait for it to come
out on streaming I'll just wait for it
to come out on video on demand you know
and like he does talk about in that
thing where he was talking about Marvel
he speaks on on Pixar like Pixar is the
greatest example of how that brand has
been so tarnished like Pixar used to be
do you remember those days when Pixar
has a new movie like this is something
special we have a movie now it's
like Pixar's late like they had three
releases or something that just went
straight to video on demand or streaming
so they've
they've completely tarnished the brand
name of Pixar to have audiences just go
we'll just wait for it to come out on
Disney plus like Elementals like like
just like the like a tortoise when it
comes to whatever it's doing at the box
office right now and so a lot of the
damages that are happening in this
industry it it's there's there's like no
accountability on this decision making
that they have done and that's the part
of it that's just so laughable to me of
when he's making this statement at his
billionaire summer camp that was so
upsetting is like he's putting all this
blame on them I'm like well dude A lot
has started off with this with the
decision making they use that the studio
heads did uh when it came to the
streaming services and how that really
affected the the theater going
experiences and now they're in so much
debt because of the amount of money they
freaking dumped into it and and then
you're seeing the uh negative ripple
effect where you have streaming services
now who are like it's just costing us
money to keep this this show or movie on
our platform so we gotta remove it now
because it's just costing like this
wasn't the writer's decision you you you
you freaking cracked the whip on what
it's the same thing of like how visual
effects artists were feeling you know
that we've been hearing Non-Stop about
um like you crack the whip on them and
then you don't pay them fairly and then
now you're blaming them for being upset
like are you [__] kidding me man it's
a lot of this started with you guys so
yeah there's a lot of just terrible tone
deaf stuff um and just completely out of
touch and
um and I I think it's I think
you know when Bob the the part about it
is Bob Bob chapek uh just had a terrible
reputation for when he took over and it
was like Bob Iger should have never left
Bob Barker did this this he had a legacy
and this one interview alone this one
thing he this this statement and and
it's not just you could hear him say it
you can hear the tenor in his voice you
could hear it
you're like this guy's an [__] like
you just here right there like screw
this guy man
um it's really upsetting it was it's
like ugly it's really ugly and and uh
you're the face of you're the head of
Disney so it's in one in one interview
it is like how out of touch could you
could you possibly be in how and like
how much lack of awareness could you
have where like dude you're always
in a situation like this like this the
studios will constantly be like the bad
guys but I'm like you just made it more
clear than ever that you guys are the
bad guys uh no question about it yeah
100 yeah
um going back to Pittsburgh
now I've been rambling I'm sorry I'm
sorry I've ramble more than you to be
fair but uh Pixar yeah they used to be
critically acclaimed like critics used
to go on about how good their films were
um and it used to be something
commercial as well they seemed to hit on
both levels
um and for them to just kill it it's
absolutely insane now bye-bye yeah
just if you think back to six months ago
even him and David saslab they were both
seen as like oh yeah they're gonna save
the industry zazlav's gonna green light
all of Zack's night that's Justice
League versus coming back he's saying
that Henry Cavill he wants him in more
movies as Superman everyone's gone yeah
he's back we're back we're we're out
here right Bob Iger came back oh he's
gonna save everything forgetting that
Bob Iger he greenlit a lot of the things
and the problems that we're having now
chapek wasn't there long enough to
really derail things to the point where
you know Indiana Jones is is causing a
big issue at Disney so it's a weird
thing like it's almost like that it's
been a mask off moment and people have
kind of realized exactly what they're
like and they are corporate greedy
summer [__] I think when you when
you're actors who work for you coming
out like Mark ruffalo's being like those
Disney guys are pieces of [__] it's like
all right mate paid your paycheck but
but let's be honest yeah no one likes
their boss I'm sure my editors deep down
think this guy's a [__] [__]
um so yeah and and they're my friends as
well so they'll probably think that uh
in general but yeah just seeing all
these crazy things come out and that
interviewed it at him absolutely no
favors like coming out and you realize
how out of touch he is like you know
what Craig I'm gonna be honest with you
we're constantly talk about how we had
it you know we weren't exactly Rich when
we grew up and we didn't have jobs that
we liked and stuff and we we had a very
poor mentality
over the last four years just since I've
been working from home
I genuinely feel like I've lost touch
with a lot of like actual struggles and
I'll talk to people about the cost of
living crisis and I'll think [__]
hell but I genuinely don't know how
they're holding it together and I feel
like so lucky to be in this position
and I and some of the things they're
talking about are I'll be like I've
completely lost touch with reality
because I just haven't been in that
headspace for so long where I don't
actually fully comprehend how difficult
it is and to be a billionaire I can't
even imagine how far removed you'd be
from that when you're at the top of a
company and you're just like it's it's a
sort of let them eat cake mentality
which I don't know if you're aware of
that saying but basically like the queen
of France there were there were people
writing and going mental in France and
kicking off because there was complete
inequality and the Queen Mary Antoinette
I think it is someone correct me in the
comments said let let them eat cake
and that was basically showing how out
of touch he was because she was
suggesting that poor people could just
eat cake like she'd been eating you know
what I mean like yeah just do whatever
you want I don't understand why people
are struggling it's great for us and I
feel like that they're in that position
too like they're hanging out at the
billionaire summer Club wherever it's
called and gone like oh yeah people
asking for ten dollars extra a day those
bloody [__]
um and it just feels so tone deaf get
bye-bye go the hell away from the camera
he's gonna absolutely destroy your stock
people are gonna hate them even more and
when it comes to strikes and versus you
know workers versus corporations
people are never going to side with the
corporation I mean there will be some
people because I say that but
in general I think most people want to
hear the stories you know I'm never
gonna feel bad for David zazlove getting
half a billion dollars you know what I
mean I think I'll feel bad for for
someone who you know worked on She-Hulk
the Daredevil episode and was saying
that in residuals they've got like I
don't know like something I I'll try and
get the um the the true number up but
did you see that there was a a She-Hulk
writer talking about oh yeah the guy who
the guy who wrote the Daredevil episode
and then yeah which is a massive massive
episode yeah it's the one everyone like
yeah yeah they they everyone tuned in
for it so Cody Ziegler the residual
check for my episode of She-Hulk
attorney at law was 396 which is
absolutely crazy now how much would
Disney have made of that episode but we
know because the budgets for these shows
have came out and they spent something
like 225 million dollars on She-Hulk now
obviously a lot goes into that do but
yeah exactly like where did that money
go you know what I mean because the
writers clearly aren't really getting it
now another issue that's came up with
the writers strike is just how streaming
has kind of changed the format of
everything and
normally on a season like back in the
day on TV you'd have 22 Episodes oh God
yeah writers would come in they'd um sit
in the writer's room you know right out
the whole thing 22 Episodes it gets
shown on TV yeah and every time there
was a rerun they'd then make money from
that exactly now for streaming services
everything's like you know eight to ten
episodes Max it's very rare that you get
If Ever I don't think I've ever seen a
streaming show that's like 22 Episodes
per long right now what's happening in
that is
the the it's not considered a rerun if
they show it on a streaming service so
every time it gets a view the people
behind it don't really get residual
checks in the way that they would back
in the old days when you know it was
shown as a rerun because it's always on
the platform it's always there it's not
technically being rerun people are just
clicking it and watching it because then
you have commercials which pay for stuff
and then and then here it's just like uh
they the companies rely on monthly
subscriptions and that's why the actors
and writers they were trying to come up
with the going back to where you're
bringing up earlier they were trying to
come up with a a third-party way of well
here's how the numbers break down you
know and so let's let's cooperate again
trying to adjust to the evolution of the
industry right now but not adjust the
workers pay but they still want the same
amount of work if not more uh it's it's
ridiculous
box sets as well people used to buy VHS
DVD box sets don't really sell them
anymore because everything's on a
streaming service the streaming services
don't even make them for example Willow
you know they've got the writers in
Mayday episodes
pulled it down before I'd even been
online for a year so no one's getting
paid off that show who worked on it now
there's also moments where they actually
bring a group of writers in they pay
them a day rate
uh they sit in a room brainstorm ideas
for the season
thank you for your time that's it and
then take those ideas they now own those
ideas and they hire other writers to
come in maybe you know a smaller team so
they don't have to pay as much who then
write the season out there's lots of
practices where they're just cutting the
working people out in order to get their
ideas not pay them for like properly in
the way that you would get bonus checks
it's sort of like a tip almost like if
you work as a waiter I don't mean you do
the work and then you kind of if you get
a tip it helps to bump your wager but
imagine those tips just being taken away
yeah and you're now hitting a point
where you're struggling again you know
there's always going to be a side to it
where people are saying well I work a
dream job they they should be happy they
get paid but everyone deserves
especially if a company's making
potentially billions off you everyone
just deserves the right to live but if
they work full time they deserve the
right to live and have like
a steady wage you know yeah again with
the to this whole 22 episode thing you
know if you did 22 weeks of work that's
going to carry you through most of the
air for example like when we get a TV
show and it's like
10 10 episodes or something and we're
covering it every week me and Greg will
always talk behind the scenes and
breathe aside relief because we're like
oh thank God we've got 10 steady weeks
of a TV show that we can cover weekly
and we're not gonna have to worry about
what the content is going to be that
week now that's gonna obviously
translate if you're in any job yet
locked down for a big project and then
they buy the next season and so on and
you could potentially be working for
years and years on a TV show and then at
the end of it if it does really well
you're getting residual checks and so on
all of that model has been completely
taken away and now they're not they're
getting the bare minimum because the
studio just wants to keep all the
figures everything they can to
themselves to make it so that they don't
have to pay out because the the average
average writer and average actor the
reason why residuals are so important
you know like these guys aren't paid
hourly you know they're paid a sometimes
a salary and sometimes like here's your
gonna be your commission for this and
then here's the residuals you can earn
on it
the average writer and actor they once a
job is done
vast majority of the vast majority you
you said something like 160 000 actors
right vast majority do not have another
job lined up you know I I'm I know
there's so many working there's so many
actors whose names you you don't know
but there's there's but they are working
actors I know quite a few of them out
here
just not long ago I was bumped into a
friend uh at the gym who like he does a
lot of like a few lines on a show a few
lines in a movie like he's he's never
been like the lead in anything but he's
been doing this for like 20 years just
like a few lines here a few lines there
a few lines here a few lines there and
you know I was at the gym with him and
he just checked he's like oh I just got
a residual check for like 300 or
something like that like and he was so
relieved because he didn't have another
job for like he didn't have a job for
like a month and a half or something
like that so he's like oh I needed this
300 you know and this is why it's so
important to be paying fairly especially
when you're venturing into the industry
uh for this and and I can guarantee you
guys if anyone who's listening to this
a lot if you are an aspiring writer if
you're an aspiring actor You're Gonna
Want to support what they're fighting
for because this is the thing that they
need to change and then if they change
you will be able to if you happen to
start succeeding in the industry in that
profession it's because of what they're
fighting for right now where you're
going to be able to have these proper
benefits and proper rewards uh for the
services that you complete so you're
gonna want to be in you're going to want
them to succeed in this in this endeavor
that they are fighting for right now
it's really important because I know
yeah I'll hear that I'll hear that
negative outcome too that you're talking
about or the the negative feedback that
some people say and I'm like well if you
are pursuing this you're going to want
to be paid fairly especially when you
know what the pay scale was like
um prior to all this and knowing that
the Studios have the capacity to make a
change to adjust instead of just being
greedy and wanting to pocket as much for
themselves when they're already cutting
down on so much else
yeah I think if you're against the
strikes you should ask yourself why
don't I want people to be paid fairly
yeah and if you want to write it in the
comments that's totally fine but I mean
I I completely I can ah to be honest I I
I'll even admit you know when I first
heard about it Brewing I was thinking
like why are these rich famous guys
going on strike and then when you
actually realize like no it's they might
be the face of the strikes they're the
people who are getting the interviews
and the headlines but there's hundreds
of thousands of people who are affected
by this
um and you know when they're not they're
not losing out on money for the fun of
it you know these guys are really
living on the breadline you know the
phrase this a struggling actor is a
phrase for a reason a lot of them work
bar jobs on the side work in restaurants
as way as and they'll do the odd job on
you know a Saturday one day and get a
bit of money from doing that I mean um
the average actor auditions uh look at
it like this for if you're if you're not
an actor right the app the average actor
is constantly doing job interview job
interview job interview job interview
and most of the time they are not
getting picked for the job interview and
that often results in them having to
spend a lot of time in traffic I mean
there's this whole thing about
self-taping and stuff so if you just
look at the job interview side so
they'll the job interview after job
interview and then they okay they
finally get a job and the reason they're
putting in that sacrifice of all that
time committed to being declined all the
time like ever the average actor will
tell you like they're used to rejection
because of this process
so part of it is to be able to have that
as the security net of like but if I get
if I happen to get a good job after the
countless times of getting turned down
and being told no
then because the average actor does not
get an offer the average actor has to do
the job interview the the audition
process and they they should be rewarded
properly if they do end up Landing the
gig is yeah I'm just trying to make it
in like the most simplistic terms for
people to understand like no they this
is why they should be paid what they're
asking for
yeah it's it's hard to get the job and
if you get the job you're not even going
to be paid fairly for it so that's
that's basically how it works
um so yeah lots of things to Stew over
you know it's gonna be an interesting
cup I think it will go on for months you
know I genuinely think that we're going
to hit a point where the studio is going
to drag it out as long as possible and
as they've said the end games to allow
things to drag on until union members
start losing their apartments and losing
their homes that's how
they don't care they don't give a [__]
like if surely you want to organize it
before that point you don't want you the
people at work be going homeless I don't
get why there's like a Obsession it's
they're not even asking for that much
more money when you when it boils down
to all they're asking for is the
protection of their image which we
should all have that right no no company
that we work if you think about the jobs
you've had in the past that you've left
imagine if they would they you'd quit
there and they were still using your
look your voice your image to sell stuff
and make money for themselves you'd be
pretty angry so that they're asking for
Productions on that
better back end pay so if the show does
well they're not even saying like give
us the money before we start they're
saying once the show's actually
successful and popular and people are
watching it and you're making money from
it just a slight bit of that pie if it
does well we deserve something off that
which is totally fair enough if you I
mean if you if you're an actor and you
deliver an incredible performance in a
TV show or if you're a writer and you
write let's just say the best episode of
She-Hulk then
sure like you do probably deserve
something off the back end for that for
how how good it is I wasn't a big fan of
She-Hulk but I thought the Daredevil
episode was good but even those other
bad ones you know if people were
watching it other people enjoyed it and
so on if it's done well then yeah fair
enough give them a little kickback
I mean yeah
if you're part of creating it you know
that's the important word actors and
writers they are part of creating the
product they're building this together
and they deserve to be compensated
proper like if they're if it's
continuing to reap money they should
have a piece of that in some way that's
paid fairly when they are the ones who
helped actually create the thing it's
it's plain and simple it's really really
simple
yeah now obviously the strikes are
affecting people just beyond the actors
and right as where people in the
entertainment industry as well and I
know Greg you've put together a lot of
research
um for people who might be listening to
the podcast or curious who are either
content creators influencers whatever so
what have you discovered in terms of are
we allowed to still review films are we
allowed to
do reviews and promote things for movies
what's happening
yeah uh I mean yesterday just to be
completely upfront with you guys I was
because I was on social media and
obviously and on my end I have one host
uh at real rejects who is a sag member
and so they were being told like hey uh
I can't talk about anything that is a
new movie and I was like okay that's
fine and then I have like someone who is
like pre-sag so they're not exactly sag
they're still technically non-union but
they're SAG eligible and then I have
another host who is a non-union member
who formally so is like okay this is
getting a little bit confusing I myself
um used to be sag like 10 years ago so I
was like I want to make sure that
everything I'm doing is okay as well and
then you know when I was going on social
media there you know you'll see some
influencers and you know tech people who
know me know I'm not a big fan of the I
don't have a problem with influencers
there's something about that word that's
always just sounded silly to me but at
the end of the day uh you know people
like Paul and I as content creators we
still fall under the category of
influencers and I was like I still want
to make sure that what we're doing it
did stem from this it was that I wanted
to make sure that what we're doing is
still going to be okay that it's not in
any violation or as seen as something
that you know is not in solidarity
Rarity with the strike because of course
we're and we support like obviously we
we support this strike uh a thousand
percent so I wanted to make sure that
what we were doing was still okay and so
yeah I did go through the entire like
this is a long time I was spending on
this because I was seeing some you know
influencers who might have talked about
something and then they're being told
like hey you shouldn't be talking about
that I was like okay I want to make sure
that what we're doing is all right and I
think it's important you know if even if
you're just a viewer of uh someone
else's content or other influencers uh
to to know like what is okay and what
isn't okay uh right now especially if
you care for them to be following the
the guideline set forth uh by sag to
show that you are in support of it I
think that's the part that it's
important if you are an influencer it's
good to know this and if you are someone
who just cares to know what the
influencer you follow is doing I think
it's just good to know this so
yes we had the uh strike memo that was
sent out but then the other thing that
happened was there was this like FAQ
that was released for influencers that
had these questions as an influencer can
I still do brand Partnerships can I
promote screenings and content produced
by struck companies struck companies um
you know obviously like Universal
apparently any company that is a bit
major Studio basically what if I'm under
contractor there's all these like
questions that they were asking
and you know at least at least for like
people like Paul and I
um on our end and this is for majority
of influencers
we are non-union influencers these
questions that were asked what was
causing people to be in a bit of a panic
because I I live in LA the heart of the
strike right now I was getting a bunch
of text messages from fellow Youtubers
of like I don't know what's okay and
what I can and cannot do and like I'm
reading this FAQ and it's like I feel
like I can't say anything I feel like I
can't do anything I can't talk about
anything new now the restrictions are
pretty much exactly what you would
expect just actors to not be able to do
you know like
paid gigs doing anything in agreeance
with the studios
um no promotional work for any of the
uh the things you've worked on or
anything like that like like it's it's
pretty much like yeah you can't do any
of that now for non-in non-union
influencers uh which is I believe which
is like majority of the influencers you
probably follow there are probably there
might be some who are union but for
majority or non-union
uh what it's specifically stipulates is
any non-member seeking future membership
in sag-aftra who performs covered work
or services for a struck company during
the strike will not be admitted into
membership in sag-aftra and to my
understanding it's in perpetuity so the
thing that puts you at most risk is if
you ever want to be part of sag-aftra if
you do any cover work or Services
then that would ultimately not allow you
to ever become part of sag-aftra and
immediately people start you know
worrying of like I can't review movies
or I can't talk about movies I can't do
any of this stuff
and that was a good thing that Paul and
I were talking about too I was like dude
I don't even know if we can do the
podcast like I don't know if I can do
the podcast I'm in the US like I don't I
can't I can't risk this and this is what
like everyone was concerned about and
then some people would be attacking him
a certain Implement not everybody I feel
like most people were like understanding
but you know of course there'd be those
camps who were like attacking
influencers uh wanting to being like ah
you shouldn't be talking about this
stuff
however you know if you go through it
of what covered services are
the basic version I could pretty much
lay it out on is like covered worker
services or or jobs or tasks protected
by a Union's rules and contracts right
so in in a nut if okay the basic example
is to be like what about like for people
like Paul and I on our end you know like
can we review secret Invasion can we
review that that falls more under that
falls under the category of not like a
traditional promotional service so
reviewing a film is generally seen as an
act of Journalism or critique it's not a
promotional service it would be a
completely different case though the
thing that a a covered service would be
a covered work would be like if
Disney hit us up or any studio hit us up
that is part of this Alliance and said
hey we want you to cover this even if it
was just a written even if it was just
an agreement to cover it not even be
paid for it but just agreeing to do it
then that runs into the part of it where
it's like okay that will prevent you
from Ever Getting in the SAG you can be
looked at as a scab obviously so
basically no Financial transactions no
agreeing to Brand deals from from
Studios like my myself right now like
sometimes we do these brand deals and
then ultimately it links back at the end
of the day to a studio so I got like
three that I already agreed to so if you
are an influencer who already has a
contractual obligation that you uh agree
to before this strike happened so if you
see an influencer doing you know an
agreement they might have already done
that agreement prior to the sack strike
actually happening and like for myself I
have three after those three if any of
anything I already told my uh brand
managers anything from Studios cannot do
I want to make sure I'm not we're not
getting if we get an offer pass on it
right away I already told them that so I
got three left and so that's one part of
it and
um yeah so promotional Works no official
agreements
just basically any kind of like Mutual
understanding of like working to promote
a film like sometimes there are these
screenings that happen like these
influencer events like I went to one for
the flash as a as a guest for someone I
actually wasn't officially invited
myself I went as a guest for someone but
I saw in their contract agreements to
attend the screening
uh even though they're not being paid to
attend
they had to uh do social media posts
about being at the premiere like that
was part of the agreement so that's off
the table so things like that are the
things that if you're a non-union
influencer if you're worried about am I
crossing the picket line here am I doing
something that is in violation
what you mainly have to do is just make
sure you're not agreeing to any type of
obviously like don't take on an acting
gig for them you know don't do anything
like that obvious like the the main
obvious but in terms of like what a lot
of us especially in this category
reviews should be okay there's nothing
in here that stipulates
um about reviews reviews should be okay
and and in my in my personal opinion and
movie news should be okay as well
because we are not being there's not
none of what we do has ever been in in
conjunction with sag after a union rules
in my personal opinion and I don't know
how you feel about this Paul
um and this is like strictly like
editorial personal opinion
I feel like if we
you know if if the studio if they really
like hey anyone any critic if you're
reviewing a movie like anyone on Rotten
Tomatoes if you're reviewing a movie you
don't stand with sag uh I don't feel
like that would help because that's what
it started sounding like to people like
you just can't even review a movie uh
but I think if you're not allowed to do
that that would actually go heavily
against that wouldn't help the SAG
strike cause you want people to still at
least I would imagine you would you
would want people to still review the
movies and be able to talk about them
not any covered service recovered work
sort of fashion but still be able to
talk about them in a way uh to to help
you know edify uh the film and work
because if if you're not giving a
conversation to these films and if it
affects the box office performance in
some way
then that only helps the studios to be
like look no one's even talking about
your film The Box Office you know
terribly why should we pay you guys more
yeah I think it it would actually
contradict it so yeah I I know that was
kind of a very long-winded explanation I
just wanted to make sure I was speaking
concisely on that matter uh so because I
I do think that's important too to pay
attention to if like if the if there's
someone you follow and you're seeing
them do like pay gigs for it then you
know where they stand uh on something
like that and if that matters to you you
know that's your decision of whether or
not you want to continue to to follow
them uh in that regard and I want to
make sure that what we're doing is in
the same guideline that is not in
violation of of anything like every
decision I'm making
I think if you see someone who is
posting something you know maybe give
them a bit of the benefit of the doubt
first because it is very confusing and
they might not be so perfect so don't
come after them with pitch folks and
call them like a scab uh because they
went to the Barbie screening or
something just be like oh by the way you
know this kind of violates the rules uh
just to make sure you know that you're
totally aware of this and if they're
still like I'm aware and I hate you guys
then maybe be like okay well get the
pitchforks out and kill them
um so yeah there's obviously
to summarize that if you're an
influencer or a reviewer watching this
reviews are fine you're more than free
to talk about films
um but when it's doing things that are
siding with the studio working alongside
them taking on influencer roles that
they're paying you for or have given you
certain contractual obligations that you
need to fill out then that's when it
starts to blur the lines a bit and you
should just be careful now I think in
general just general rule of thumb if
you're unsure
and maybe don't do it or try and find
out if you should do it that that's just
a general rule of thumb in life if
you're kind of around the side of
caution yeah if you if you get hit up
with something inside will you do this
and you're kind of like ah don't I mean
I guess I could but in general just be
like maybe I shouldn't do it then yeah
like I mean the last thing I'll I'll
talk about the the one subject that
where I'm really I'm personally at a
loss about I really I do not know I I
don't want to clarify I I don't know uh
because like I was telling you a couple
weeks ago I was invited to an
Oppenheimer screening
this strike happened and the Oppenheimer
screening is tonight
and then part of the thing that the
strike order memo stipulates is
premieres and screenings but it's not
super detailed so I'm like is this only
for like screenings like oh you know
like the director can't show up for a
screening or if you're a sag member you
can't go but if I am I it does is it in
violation of me to go to a press
screening
for Oppenheimer I'm not saying it is or
it isn't it's like to me I'm like I I
don't know is it in violation for me to
go to a press screening because the
studio put it together to me I'm like
okay I mean it might be considered cover
work or covered Services uh just because
the studio themselves is holding it
together it's a completely different
story if I'm paying C Oppenheimer and
then I review it
but because the studio was putting this
screening together it could be seen as
cover worker covered services I don't
know if it's just an Optics perspective
or not I don't I truly don't know what
the answer is on that I'm airing on the
side of caution and just not attending
because even though every you know a lot
most of the movies if you see me give a
very negative review about them
I've been usually it's a press screening
I've been to it's because I'm not
required to promote the film and in fact
I've never signed anything that says I
have to talk about the movie you know uh
so as much as I love to go to an early
screening to get a review out because I
got a Comic-Con this week that I gotta
leave for we got a panel I'm not gonna
have time to see Oppenheimer so like as
much as I love to go see it
I'm ultimately I'm like I just don't
know what the right choice is right now
and I'm not going to fault someone who
does go to their press stream I'm not
gonna like attack them and be like what
you're doing is wrong because I'm like I
really don't know so I'm sitting on the
side of caution so again what I'm saying
is is that I know that's a big
stipulation as well but I I don't quite
know what the what the category is of
what if that's okay or if that isn't
okay
um so yeah you know just if you don't
really know the answer don't attack
someone on this is what I'm saying
yeah and don't expect everyone to know
the exact same things that you do
because yeah it's very complicated
so yeah thanks uh for going through that
Greg I know that was a lot to unpack as
well so uh hopefully that's cleared
stuff up if you've got more comments on
it or questions
comments below
I think a lot of people as well have
been asking me in general like how are
the strikes going to affect your channel
and yeah to make it all me me but you
might notice that we kind of have almost
been planning for for something going on
like this yeah now I'm not gonna say I'm
a futurist like Tony Stark but uh a
couple of so a couple of years ago I was
diagnosed with anxiety and I connected
to this job I'm guessing
um and you know I got offered medication
I turned it down and the way that I
thought I'm gonna deal with it is to
mentally just try and think ahead and
then ease my worries by
planning and you know putting things in
place that are gonna lower my stress
levels and anxiety and just make me kind
of plan ahead so you know we've been
feeling like the the strikes are going
to have an impact on this far in the
future which you know as we mentioned in
episode one that's why we started the
podcast so we've at least got something
regularly we can do and also the the
classic movie breakdowns that was
another idea I had where it was like
you know if stuff goes to hell I'm just
I just want to build a following who
like watching me talking about older
movies and if we hit a month where
nothing's getting released because
there's been strikes then I can just
review all of the Terminator films or
something like that you know what I mean
so that that was my plan of what how I
how I'm gonna handle it now
Greg you're sort of doing something
similar obviously on the podcast with me
as well
um
and yeah it's just it's just kind of I
mean we'll be fine we're not the victims
here or anything it's uh I just covered
A Few Good Men Paul I am going through
the archives right now which is
enjoyable for us as well though to be
honest I I am actually enjoying going
back to the older movies
um it's a nice palette cleanser
um it's kind of given us a break
I I worry that I'm now coming across
like I'm I'm glad it's happening but
yeah it's been nice kind of just putting
this plan in place you know it's helped
ease my stress and seeing the response
on the podcast it's been really really
helpful you guys have been so supportive
the classic movie breakdowns as well
um the shinings just hit a million views
or aliens videos about hit a million
interstellars like three million it's
absolutely crazy
I'm starting to think like should I just
do them in general
try our videos and stuff that's getting
up to do Secret Invasion
um so yeah so I mean thank you for all
your support you know it has helped ease
that anxiety and
it you know if worse comes to us for us
we will still keep pushing content out
we've got some exciting developments
coming down the line you know it's been
some crazy stuff happening in YouTube in
general at the moment
um in our community and you know been
talking about stuff behind the scenes
with people and hopefully you guys enjoy
what's coming Greg is there anything you
want to you look a bit puzzled I've told
you before what's going on but no this
is just my resting [__] face okay yeah
like I'm thinking I'm just thinking I'm
not even I don't even have like an
active thought this is my this is my
focus face that's just your whole life
in general you just don't have any
thoughts at all yeah
yeah but thanks guys uh podcast is
always available on Spotify Amazon music
YouTube watch it on YouTube yeah because
it's got ads in it so we'll get paid for
that uh but yeah Greg is anything you
want to final word this is the third
time you're asking me this time I'm okay
we can end we can say bye thanks guys
thank you thank you guys